I want to jump to this story we got from
The Daily Mail Poland starts handing out
anti-radiation tablets as battle rages
around Ukraine nuclear power plant I
don't think it's the nuclear power plant
but they do mention Putin's fresh nuke
threat so I believe this is a potassium
iodide yup potassium iodide tablets okay
first as a PSA to everybody to explain
what this is it's basically iodine what
happens you eat it it goes into your
thyroid when your body absorbs as much
as it can it will reject the rest if
radioactive iodine is in the air or on
the ground or all over the place and
you're eating your body will absorb it
and put radioactive iodine in your
thyroid which then causes problems this
does not protect you from anything else
people seem to think that like if
there's a nuclear bomb that goes off you
take one of these and it protects you
from the radiation like it protects your
thyroid from iodine but there's I mean I
don't know exactly what kind of
radioactive materials are going to be
littered all over the place but I do
want to talk to everybody about the
threat of nuclear war and what it really
means and I'll bring up a good story uh
Luke and I we went to Fukushima and they
they told us uh I don't do we didn't
take potassium iodide when we went did
we I don't think so no but we they gave
us suits yeah and the suits were just
cloth suits and I was kind of like don't
you have to have like some kind of
special material and they're like no no
what the suits do is when the dust and
the particles land on you when you leave
you take it all off so it's not on you
and then you take a shower to wash it
all off and I was like oh okay I thought
it was like for like radiation and they
were like Alpha and beta particles they
stick to you you then eat stuff it gets
in your system
but with Fukushima there was MOX
plutonium and there was iodine 131 or
something like that the MOX plutonium
was a heavy metal lit on the ground it
sinks it drops the iodine kicks up so
you take one of these pills but then you
pick something up off the ground and you
can get some you know MOX plutonium or
whatever it's called on you that ain't
doing anything for you so in the event
of nuclear war the other thing to
consider not every nuclear bomb has a
radioactive yield that's my
understanding is that's intentional
when a bomb goes off and it leaves
radiation like they design it to do that
and there are many nuclear bombs that
actually don't they just do Fireballs so
yeah our understanding of nuclear
weapons is still primitive compared to
the advancements that were made within
what what was it like 90 years 80 years
since the 80s yeah 80 years so so what
we know of the nuclear weapon 80 years
ago is absolutely nothing compared to
what's out there right now and the
technology and the possibilities that
they have Putin and the Russian
government a lot of times talk about
flooding all of the United Kingdom with
a radiation wave and using nuclear
weapons under uh water as a way to start
a tsunami that is going to cover all of
the United Kingdom this is what they
talk about they even made Graphics they
even made a cartoon about this on
Russian State television which is uh
just uh absolutely perplexing and insane
I got a question why would Russia not
have rods from God
um why would they not have why would the
U.S not have that so that's not familiar
it's a theoretical weapon where you put
a uh a series of tungsten rods in a
satellite and it drops them in the force
of gravity it's like what like a hundred
times more powerful than a nuke of the
same size or something yeah some
ridiculous massive explosive yield
um they might who knows I don't know
like I'm not familiar enough with
technology here's my point it's not it's
not so much about what the technology is
it's that no one even knew they were
building nukes in the first place yeah
there was speculation about this big
project that was going on some thought
that it could be a nuclear weapon some
thought it was going to be a death ray
some thought it was teleportation or
time travel people believed crazy things
and then loan bill turned out to be this
massive explosive device yeah the
Manhattan Project that was uh
spearheaded and started at the Bohemian
Grove of all places where a hundred
thousand people were working on it and
only about two dozen knew exactly what
they were working on right I mean that
said uh I don't know the the way I read
have you read the making of the atomic
bomb by Richard Rhodes no I have a very
very great book by the way when I was
looking into the Bohemian Grove and then
they were just bragging oh the the
nuclear bomb was pretty much created
here and I'm like kind of I mean the the
my understanding based on that book was
that there were a series of experiments
done and publicized in like 1939 1940 in
Germany of all places yep uh where
basically they've I think they split the
uranium atom yeah so uh actually I
upload the Wikipedia discovery of
nuclear fission by German chemists look
at that 1938 how right am I am I right
am I right and then Germany could have
developed a nuclear weapon but they
kicked out their scientists because they
had a pre they had a religion that they
didn't like kicked out and all the
scientists went to the United States and
they started building it here in the
United literally the the Nazis
anti-Semitism is is actually a pretty
good argument that maybe it's not
exactly why they lost World War II but
it made their loss inevitable I mean if
Hitler had the nuclear bomb before
anybody else
as well like the development of of
German technology in in the early uh
parts of that world world war were
absolutely just beyond belief you want
to continue with what you're saying that
1940 there so basically but like once
this experiment happened and there were
scientists around the world having seen
this experiment understood the
implication was a nuclear bomb as
possible and so that's you know so
Germany started working on it we started
working on it I think England you know
other countries started working on it
too um so it wasn't when you like I
guess it wasn't a secret at that point
it was sort of if you were in the
scientific Community it was like all the
scientists started talking to the
politicians of like we know this is
possible you should really invest in
this because you don't want the other
guy to get this first because it's just
how much energy was necessarily created
from splitting the uranium atom it was
was enough to make people realize that
it could create a chain reaction on a
bomb and I would even argue you know
Germany Lost World War II but I would
say the Nazis didn't
how so I mean do you mean because Verner
Ron Brown came down one a lot of them
went to Argentina two the Russians and
the Americans scooped them up right
after the war and then had them work on
on NASA had them work on the Russian
space agency what was that was that
paperclip uh yeah Operation Paperclip
and uh the the the the death of Hitler
is still being contested by many
historians there was no body as well so
he could have been in Argentina this
whole time uh Argentina gave them safe
haven and but they did lose that doesn't
mean that's not winning their influence
escaped like I'm making a very nuanced
kind of argument yeah I'm saying that
that the ideology was passed on through
a lot of the top figures being saved uh
through operation pay-per-click I don't
know I mean I wouldn't call Verner Von
Braun like a top Nazi I mean he was a
member of the Nazi party but he was a
rocket scientist right like in that he
didn't that was you know he was a rocket
scientist in Germany
um not saying he wasn't a bad guy or a
good guy I'm just saying like he wasn't
gebels you know some ideologist who's
spreading it and then you look at people
like Eichmann you know was the classic
guy who went to Argentina I mean he he
had to be Incognito for 20 years before
the Israelis finally found him kidnapped
him and tried him in Israel and not to
mention there's a bunch of really crazy
stories
um like the uh what is it was it the
istal woman I think it was called I went
to uh there's an amazing story I went to
Bergen Norway a while back and there's
this Legend they have where they found a
woman dead up in the mountain just
outside of town from smoke inhalation
they said and it's been a long time
since I've gone through the story we
interviewed a bunch of people in Bergen
and uh there are like passports outfits
and so one of the leading theories was
that she was Mossad hunting down escaped
Nazis in various countries
and they were being summarily executed
so not escaping but in this instance
this woman was killed by the person she
was sent to assassinate and so they
found her body didn't know she was saw a
bunch of aliases and passports never
figured it out but people are like they
believe that Mossad went on for decades
probably even still now are hunting
these people down there there was a
story out there long ago like a guy was
like 90 something years old was it like
98 yeah I heard of that and he was like
a Nazi guard and they found him
yeah I think they deported him I think
there was a Netflix movie about that I
think it was like a it was like some
well here's what people don't know
here's what people don't understand is
that many of these people who did Escape
probably died within a year from
assassinations and it's not in the news
it's not gonna be in history books a lot
of prominent people are connected to you
know that history whether it's Soros
Arnold Schwarzenegger uh the Canadian
um the minister lady I forgot her name
right now uh but she also has ties to a
lot of that darker kind of history but
uh you know this is something that you
know my people have kind of lived
through being from Poland we hear about
this all the time you know this is
something that my family uh you know
lost a lot of of its members to and uh
it's still something that you know I
think in hindsight should be talked
about more especially with the severe
escalations we're seeing in Europe right
now that many people believe is going to
prompt Another World War which is just
absolutely insane yeah Nazism wasn't
stopped the German Third Reich was
stopped but Nazism wasn't it went to it
was in eastern Ukraine it still is they
call him the azov now the azov Battalion
it's like a Neo-Nazi group wasn't there
a picture of a guy standing with
zelenski that had like the black sun
logo or something yeah it is genuinely
true that the zelenski government is way
too friendly with straight up like Annie
semites yeah I mean that was they were
roundly I mean they named one of their
major streets after a guy named Stephan
Bandera yeah who was involved in pogroms
against the Jewish community in advance
of the Germans coming in
um you know and and they're all these
guys they're hailing is like Ukrainian
Heroes and Ukrainian nationalists well
those are the guys who like fought the
Russians and sided with the Nazis and
usually we're doing the Nazis bidding
before the Nazi showed up well Ukrainian
is also in a tough position because
that's someone of the best fighters that
they have and the Ukrainian government
is like okay let's stop talking about
this because we need to fight a war and
this is how they're kind of excusing it
but they there's a there's a whole I
think a battalion inside of the official
Ukrainian military that was officially
recognized that did have extreme
far-right kind of idea you know ideas
and there's no denying that it's
something that of course the Russians
kind of bring up all the time uh but
this is you know a battalion and a lot
of the stuff gets contested here but but
you're not wrong Ian it's a yeah it is a
is of regiment uh formed from volunteers
integrated into the National Guard of
Ukraine at least this is what I've been
told is Ezra the azovar the uh the
neo-nazis that's the symbol is like it's
basically a swastika at an angle not a
complete swastika but it's got you know
I don't know if you put yeah there it is
that blue symbol on the right
uh I don't know this is what I hear this
propaganda but I can't imagine being in
the United States and hearing propaganda
that are supposed
not merely propaganda like that it
there's there's real truth to that I
mean you can look into
um you know a Jewish associations
lighting up the Ukrainian government for
their actions in support of azov and a
lot of their public resurrection of
these uh World War II figures who were
uh anti-semitic another the problem with
war is pushing countries to war is that
the worst I'm not saying that the azov
are the worst but you violent extremists
will rise up to fight because those
might be your best fighters because
they're violent extremists that's what
they do is they don't fight this weird
like problem for Ukrainian nationalism
in general right because Ukraine doesn't
have this long and deep history as an
independent nation so they're they're
kind of have to reach for these figures
of nationalist pride in Ukraine who have
these very very checkered pasts I'd love
to see Ukraine become a neutral
territory in some way like like
Switzerland like it's in it's in a
position where it should be it's like
it's like the cerebral
it should have been a buffer state that
would have been much better for
everybody right much better for it's
flat so it's not Ukraine or like a Hong
Kong or like a Singapore but there but
Ukraine also has a lot of natural gas
and a lot of energy exploration is being
found in that country which threatens
the Russian Petro State and this is I
think another reason why Russia is being
so aggressive especially in the southern
Parts where a lot of this new energy has
been found and will contest Russia as a
Petro State uh and contend with it
directly which of course Russia can't
have because that's one of its major uh
assets is it's energy that it provides
the world oil gas oil energy yep
so yeah complex situation very confusing
lots of different sides lots of
different atrocities no one wins in war
and and uh please my goodness let's try
to call for some de-escalations here and
stop with this madness and people dying
for the whims of politicians and their
aspirations thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at
8pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there